[Música]
escala en París Braulio Moro
Bienvenidos a escala en París una
emisión de radio Francia internacional
en colaboración con la televisión Franz
24 en español en la que cada semana
damos la palabra a personas del mundo de
las ciencias las artes la cultura los
deportes la política y claro está de la
sociedad civil hoy recibimos en nuestro
estudio a un virtuoso de la música o un
explorador de las percusiones a uno de
los grandes representantes de la música
cubana el percusionista habrán más farol
Abraham Bienvenido a esta escala en
París Muchas gracias Braulio vamos a
escuchar un poco de su música para que
ustedes vean Porque estamos tan
contentos de recibirlo aquí en nuestros
estudios
[Aplausos]
una parte de la presentación está hecha
estamos viendo el extracto del homenaje
que usted hizo a la figura del pensador
de Augusto Roldán Abraham usted nació en
guantánamo Cuba donde hizo sus estudios
de música escaló lo más alto de los
niveles de Educación en la isla ya hace
dos décadas que se instaló aquí en
Francia cómo fue su formación musical en
Cuba la formación musical en Cuba
es muy rigurosa porque tuve que hacer
todas las partes clásicas estudiar el
timpan y el xilófono y luego
paralelamente la percusión cubana las
tradiciones los batatas los tambores
de la tumba francesa los tambores Sí
también de la de abacoa
mucha mucha
exigencia pero al final el resultado es
es Genial porque no sabes dónde va a ir
pero sabes dónde hasta dónde puede
llegar y hay que decir que galardones
Claro claro que sí y ahí estando allá
usted inició un proceso antes de
instalarse en Francia que se llama piapa
háblenos de eso qué significa piapa Y de
dónde nació esta iniciativa
tres sonido
piapa piapa se creó en el año
1997 en la Habana hicimos una
presentación para el gran trompetista
norteamericano Wilton marsalis luego esa
presentación hicimos un viaje a España y
hicimos una colaboración con una con una
coral en Francia con solitudi Y a partir
de ahí siguió
me instalé en Francia y desarrollé
piapal concepto y de piayapa en Francia
con un percusionista indio un
percusionista que toca las personas
africana y un percusionista que se
dedica a las producciones brasileña un
gran explorador entonces usted se define
Claro está como un músico curioso como
un creador de sorpresas desde ahí que
surge esta idea precisamente de utopía
guantánamera también el disco
Imagine Imagine usted que cuando un
músico exiliado tiene una una especie de
nostalgia de su país y yo era de
guantánamo y yo quería hacer una utopía
hacer música cubana en París es es
parece una ciudad con cosmopolita pero
hay que saber que hay hay permite hay
espacio para todos todo tipo de cultura
y después voy a hacer la música cubana
mis tradiciones desde París por eso puse
utopía aguantanamera también hay
interpretado ha hecho homenaje a otro
grande en este caso del jazz Claro claro
el homenaje fue en el año 2020
hablando con yo termina la gira de de
Chucho Valdés ya es bata y hablaba con
Chucho Valdés Chucho Valdez me dijo a
bici le debemos todo en los años 40
ayudó a los museos cubanos en los años
70 y 80 ayuduras quiere Gonzalo
Ruvalcaba muchos músicos cubanos a
hacerse conocer en en todo en todo el
mundo más porque es así como también
conocen sus seguidores la gente de la
música La gente que ama las percusiones
Cuando uno lo escucha Cuando uno lo ve
tocando Las percusiones da la apariencia
como si usted estuviera acariciando lo
instrumento como que el simple roce de
un dedo bastante para crear el sonido
más espectacular es la conexión que se
crea eso con el trabajo con el tiempo
con el tiempo la que la conexión que uno
crea con el instrumento es como como una
especie de
es cuántico es una cosa que lo incorpora
tu cuerpo forma parte del instrumento y
mismo como te dije ahorita
eso la misma mesa puede criar sorpresa
puede crear un sonido No sé lo que hay
aquí pero
Y a partir de ahí podemos desarrollar
algo ya lo habrán visto lleva la música
en el corazón a lo largo de su carrera
evidentemente ha interpretado con muchos
músicos hemos hablado ya de Chucho
Valdez vamos a volver sobre este caso
otros grandes músicos con los que usted
ha tocado la experiencia más reciente
fue con el en recalde y en el bajo y en
el piano en el piano Claro que sí Elena
recalde
presentó su nuevo disco carishina el
cual invitó la percusión lograba Vanessa
García y yo soy músico invitado para que
fumo parte del equipo que acompaño en
todas las todas las los conciertos las
giras y una experiencia interesante
quiere decir que hay libán libanés al
piano un ecuatoriana al bajo que es la
que es la la que presenta el proyecto y
un cubano la percusión es como tres
puntos de la tierra que se encuentran en
París y crean ese universo una falta de
triángulo equidistante maravilloso si se
puede decir exactamente exactamente
triángulo maravilloso y con con para que
para recrear el mundo desde Elena sepan
ustedes que habrán ha tocado le ha
correspondido tocar con muchísimos
grandes intérpretes hay que mencionar ya
lo decía Chucho Valdés el gran
compositor cubano pero también con
Ibrahim Malú con salsas
y para lo que para mí personalmente es
la el broche de oro dijéramos con las
hermanas en la casa de la Trova en
Santiago de Cuba Ese fue el primer
proyecto musical cuando cuando me
instalé en París
la hermana faez ahí hicieron un disco en
Cuba y habían dos personas que se
ocuparon desde realizar la gira estaban
buscando un percusionista cubano me
encontraron a mí me me llamaron me
dijeron Usted es la persona que
necesitamos y realizamos este una
residencia en enviarritos y
un cierto en festivales en toda Francia
luego
invitaron también al Quinteto diapasón
un Quinteto cubano y la historia de que
comentaba era que en cada cada noche el
espectáculo estaba concebido los músicos
las hermanas faes delante
dos hermanas sentadas en una mesa con
una botella de ron y la botella de ron
al final del espectáculo
botella pura la botella y muchas
personas al público pensaban que que
engañado que lo estaban engañando que
que no tomaban ron y decimos Sí eso
pongo aparte ella Ellas tienen esa
tradición ellos estaban como en su casa
eh la botella Vamos a cantar esta
canción Vamos a estar acá
y así contaban historias contaba
historia de hasta
exactamente
el músico el boncocero me engañó me dijo
algo me dijo que me que me iba a traer
flores Mira no me ha traído nada
extraordinaria las hermanas
Cómo han nutrido a usted como músico
todas este tipo de experiencias este
contacto con estos músicos tan diversos
en lo que es este recorrido de una
persona joven pero que ya tiene una gran
experiencia musical
eso te permite de saber de que la música
de la música por eso como has mencionado
todas las personas
de diferentes es que te permite
contactar
con todo tipo de de cultura sea la
cultura africana sea la cultura francesa
a la cultura cubana a la cultura
ecuatoriana Eso es para mí es una
gracias a la música como le digo a mi a
mis hijos gracias a la música he
conocido el mundo y puedo y seguiré
conociendo el mundo un gran Regalo del
mundo para usted y un gran regalo de
usted hacia el mundo a la gente que
amamos la música Claro claro pero yo me
siento yo me siento como dichoso de de
de de tener la música como como especie
de
de conexión con las con las personas su
otro ego su otra parte es otro ser claro
claro
además de ser un gran compositor
prolífico compositor es usted también un
gran explorador háblenos de las
experiencias de música que ha
desarrollado
enseñándole a los jóvenes precisamente
la música que no es una cosa sencilla
sobre todo tratándose de percusiones
aquí en Francia aquí en Francia
hay que saber como comentaba que una
ciudad cosmopolita hay muchas culturas
Es una lástima que todas las culturas no
tienen el espacio en los conservatorios
Yo tuve la suerte que que pude lograr de
entrar en dos conservatorios en Francia
y aplico muy tradición de la de la
enseñanza oralmente que le explico a los
niños cómo cómo tocar un instrumento sin
tener que leer una partitura pero
también aplico la tradición a decir
europea con una partitura cuando tienen
que tocar con un ensamble que tiene que
hacer algo que tiene la repetición de
las notaciones eso es importante y que
los alumnos como yo digo mira que es que
sean capaces de tocar mismo si no saben
lo que van a tocar y cómo lo reciben
al principio
es como es como decirle a alguien que
hable en público y nunca ha hablado en
su vida delante mismo con con tres
personas es algo es algo fortale pero yo
digo que le digo es a ellos que que más
es un ejercicio lo van a hacer que se
den confianza ellos mismos y verán que
lo pueden hacer más pues decíamos hace
ya veinte años que usted dejó Cuba ha
pensado alguna vez volver a la isla
Claro que sí quisiera yo quisiera hacer
quisiera ser dos grandes sueños el
primero es grabar un disco en Cuba y el
segundo hacer un un viaje por Cuba pero
a través del Ritmo
enseñarle a compartir con el mundo
decirle Cuba es Buena Vista Cuba Chucho
Valdés Cuba es Fran Fernández Cuba es
la tumba francesa Cuba es Polo Montañez
grandes claro grandes cantantes pero
sobre todo a presentar a través del
Ritmo pintores bailarines que la gente
Cuba no es nada más errón cigarro y Sol
etcétera Claro que vean que hay pintores
que por ejemplo hay un zoológico de
piedra natural en guantánamo una persona
que dijo nunca ha estado un zoológico
voy a crear un zoológico de piedra
quería más original entonces me gustaría
enseñar cosas así que que la gente no se
imagina pero a través del Ritmo decirle
mire en esta zona de aquí se toca el
changuí se toca el Bongo en esta zona
aquí es los batalla en esta zona aquí
pero eso con una forma una especie de
viaje no como como ahora arrastramos la
serie que es primer episodio segundo
episodio Quisiera hacer una cosa así y
ese viaje a Cuba ese disco eventualmente
en Cuba con quién lo haría
tengo muchos amigos de Cuba pero también
tengo muchos amigos aquí en Francia y
tengo muchos amigos en el mundo que
quisiera también porque Imagínese usted
que puedo invitar a un a un a un
marroquí que venga con sus instrumentos
que diga que se imagina que ha llegado a
Cuba y que pueda compartir quizás
Quisiera hacer una exploración siempre
yo me gusta explorar con como decir
poner esto aquí y dejarlo allá pero a
ver qué edad por eso la primera la
primera composición que que que que hice
cuando llegué a Francia fue el pensador
de Román porque dije cómo cómo un
homenaje a Francia puedo hacerlo dice a
través de una posición así de esto que
en el mundo todo el mundo lo conoce
sentados en un instrumento que nadie se
imagina y un cajón y Bueno pues estamos
ya llegando al final de esta escala en
París Abraham Yo quiero dejarles en
compañía de Abraham con otro grande de
la música El trompetista Ibrahim baúl
para que ustedes comprendan por qué la
importancia de tenerlo aquí con nosotros
a Abraham Abraham Muchísimas gracias por
haber venido a en París esperemos que su
sueño se haga realidad y pronto lo
veamos en una gira en Cuba Claro que sí
Muchísimas gracias a ustedes les damos
una nueva cita la próxima semana aquí en
otra escala en París y sigan esta buena
música
[Aplausos]
[Música]